accorde
si neptune possède ton désir
alors je vais tout amener sur le côté je
monte un hippocampe dans ton eau
jusqu'à ce que nous entendions cassé dans
la nature
parce qu'il
y a toi dans tout ce que je
sais
si seulement je
pouvais te voir
ce rêve
ne serait pas
si difficile
si seulement je
pouvais  te voir
ce rêve
serait
aussi très dur ouais
parce que je
sais
que si les étoiles filantes te font te demander
alors je peindrai le ciel
toute la journée
pour que nous puissions prendre de la hauteur et voler ensemble
si seulement je
pouvais te voir
ce rêve
serait
si difficile
si  seulement je
peux te voir
ce rêve
ne serait pas
si dur ouais
toi et tout connu
parce que